OK, we are ready to begin.
好的，我们准备开始了。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》节目，由国际公共广播电台发行。
When you guys are ready, we can start. OK, today we will be selecting our bride and our groom for the mock wedding.
你们准备好了吗？我们可以开始了。好的，今天我们将选出模拟婚礼的新郎和新娘。
Ms. Hannah's Adult Living class, at Rock Island High School, near the Illinois-Iowa border, has as part of its curriculum a mock wedding. These happen in high schools all over the country. And if you're from a place where they have them, they don't seem like a big deal at all. Today, before Ms. Hannah's class can choose decorations and bridesmaids outfits, before they talk to florists and a caterer, they have to choose a bride and a groom. And the money-on favorite for groom is [? DeAndrew. ?]
汉娜老师在伊利诺伊州与爱荷华州边界附近的罗克岛高中开设的成人生活课，课程的一部分是模拟婚礼。全国各地的中学都有这种活动。如果你来自有这种活动的地方，你会觉得这根本没什么大不了。今天，在汉娜老师的班级选择装饰品和伴娘礼服之前，在他们与花商和承办商谈话之前，他们必须先选出新郎和新娘。而夺冠呼声最高的新郎人选是迪安德鲁。
Because he's just the most outgoing person, the person that's actually one of the guys-- because we have very few guys-- one of the guys that are actually into it, you know?
因为他是最外向的人，也是真正融入其中的男生之一——因为我们班男生很少——他是真正喜欢这个活动的男生之一，你知道吗？
DeAndrew ?] is going to be the groom.
迪安德鲁将会成为新郎。
I think [? DeAndrew ?] will get the groom.
我想迪安德鲁会当选新郎。
Out of the boys, it's either me or [? DeAndrew. ?]
男生里，要么是我，要么是迪安德鲁。
This is Kevin, another contender.
这是凯文，另一位竞争者。
I think we're running neck and neck.
我想我们势均力敌。
Yeah, he wanted it too, but--
是的，他也想当选，但是——
This is Stacia.
这是斯泰西娅。
I don't know. I think more of the kids in the class will vote more towards [? DeAndrew, ?] because he's the class clown. He makes everybody laugh and everything.
我不知道。我觉得班里大部分孩子会投票给迪安德鲁，因为他是班里的开心果。他会让每个人发笑之类的。
As for who will be the bride, [? Jackie ?] says the girls talked about it during gym.
至于谁会成为新娘，杰基说女孩们在体育课时讨论过这件事。
?] There's not that much competition, because a lot of girls don't know if they want to be it. I think it's three girls. Me, and Heather, and [? Keena. ?] So we were the only three that really said we want to to be it. And I know a couple people that have said that they didn't want to be in it. I don't think anybody else wants to do it.
没多少竞争，因为很多女孩不知道自己想不想当。我想只有三个女孩。我和希瑟，还有基娜。所以我们三个是真正说想当选的。而且我知道有几个人说她们不想参与。我不觉得还有其他人想参加。
Ms. Hannah uses the overhead projector to walk the class through a budget for the wedding, which is $250, by the way, that the kids will have to raise themselves. Then she takes nominations. Everybody votes on little slips of paper that she hands out.
汉娜老师用高射投影仪带领全班过了一遍婚礼预算，顺便说一下是250美元，孩子们得自己筹集。然后她开始接受提名。每个人都在她发的纸条上投票。
Is there anyone who has not voted?
还有谁没投票吗？
AJ is sent to the chalkboard to tote the results as Ms. Hannah counts the ballots in a style that is less like the Illinois election commission and more like Jeff Probst from Survivor . She basically pulls out each ballot, unfolds it, and reads it.
AJ 被派到黑板前统计结果，汉娜老师像统计选票一样，只不过她的风格不像伊利诺伊州选举委员会，更像《幸存者》节目的主持人杰夫·普罗布斯特。她基本上是拿出一张选票，展开，然后大声朗读。
OK, here we go. [? DeAndrew. ?] AJ. AJ. Kevin. AJ.
好的，我们开始吧。迪安德鲁。AJ。AJ。凯文。AJ。
Ooh, look at AJ in the lead.
哦，看啊，AJ 领先了。
AJ.
AJ。
Oh, my God.
天哪。
What? Hold on.
什么？等一下。
Oh, my God.
天哪。
Even AJ looks surprised. But these early returns don't hold up, and in the end it is the predicted favorite, [? DeAndrew ?], who will be mock-marrying [? Jackie. ?] When the results are announced, [? DeAndrew, ?] who admits that he used to have a little thing for [? Jackie, ?] jumps up and sits next to her.
连 AJ 看起来都很惊讶。但这些早期的选票结果并没有保持下去，最终，预测的热门人选迪安德鲁将与杰基进行模拟婚礼。当结果宣布时，承认自己曾对杰基有点意思的迪安德鲁跳起来坐在了她旁边。
?] Yeah, I'm getting married to [? Jackie ?] [? Thompson. ?] I'm talking six, seven, nine kids.
是的，我要和杰基·汤普森结婚了。我可是打算要六、七、九个孩子的。
Of the 11 juniors and seniors who showed up for class today, one has a baby and one lives with a boyfriend. She's engaged. I asked Ms. Hannah if the idea of this curriculum is to encourage kids to get married. And to my surprise, she says no. She's just showing them how, the same way this class shows them how to rent an apartment, or buy a used car. Even here in small-town Illinois hours from the big city, even the teacher who teaches marriage has complicated feelings about marriage itself.
今天来上课的11名高二和高三学生中，有一个已经有了孩子，还有一个与男友同居。她已经订婚了。我问汉娜老师，这个课程的设计意图是不是为了鼓励孩子们结婚。令我惊讶的是，她说不是。她只是在向他们展示流程，就像这门课向他们展示如何租公寓或购买二手车一样。即使在这个离大城市几小时路程的伊利诺伊州小镇，即使是教授婚姻课程的老师，对婚姻本身也有着复杂的感受。
The students could not believe that I wasn't married when they found out I was not married. Because of all the joy and the fulfilling things that has happened to me since my divorce, I have truly experienced life. And because it has been such a grand experience being on the single side of life, I can honestly tell students that, yes, you can be single and you can be happy. You can be married and you can be happy. Some of us will be happy with the institution of marriage and some of us will not.
当学生们发现我没结婚时，他们简直不敢相信。因为离婚后我所经历的所有快乐和充实的事情，我才真正体验到了生活。正因为单身生活的经历如此美妙，我可以诚实地告诉学生们，是的，你可以单身并且过得快乐。你也可以结婚并且过得快乐。我们中的一些人会对婚姻制度感到幸福，而另一些人则不会。
What it means to be married is up in the air right now, and not just because people are fighting about whether gays should be able to marry. The number of women getting married has dropped a third since 1970. People are getting married at a later age than ever before in this country. Fewer households have children, and a fourth of all children are raised by just one parent. The number of couples living together without marrying is 10 times what it was in 1960, over 4.5 million people. So today on our radio show, a look at what it really means to be married today. Our program today, in three acts:
婚姻的意义目前尚无定论，不仅仅是因为人们在争论同性恋者是否应该有权结婚。自1970年以来，结婚的女性人数下降了三分之一。在这个国家，人们结婚的年龄比以往任何时候都要晚。拥有孩子的家庭越来越少，四分之一的孩子由单亲抚养。同居而不结婚的伴侣人数是1960年的10倍，超过450万人。所以今天在我们的广播节目中，我们来看看今天结婚的真正含义。我们今天的节目分为三幕：
Act One, What Really Happens in Marriages. Like the 15th century explorers and mapmakers, there is a generation of scientists mapping out what happens in marriages, finding out stuff that people did not know about before.
第一幕，婚姻中究竟发生了什么。就像15世纪的探险家和地图绘制者一样，有一代科学家正在描绘婚姻中发生的事情，发现人们以前不知道的东西。
Act Two, The Defense of Marriage Act. Gay marriage can hurt straight marriage. One man explains how.
第二幕，《捍卫婚姻法案》。同性婚姻可能会伤害异性婚姻。一位男士解释了原因。
Act Three, I Want to Be a Statistic. Starlee Kine gets answers about her parents' marriage from her dad after a lifetime of mystery.
第三幕，我想成为一个统计数据。斯塔莉·凯恩在经历了一生的迷茫后，从她父亲那里得到了关于她父母婚姻的答案。
That is three, yes, three big acts, each one designed to make your family happier. Plus we have a real wedding band, the Doug Lawrence Orchestra, playing us wedding standards all this hour. Hit it, boys.
这就是三幕，没错，三大幕，每一幕都旨在让你的家庭更幸福。此外，我们还有一支真正的婚礼乐队——道格·劳伦斯管弦乐队，整点为您演奏婚礼经典曲目。来吧，伙计们。
[MUSIC - "THE WAY YOU LOOK TONIGHT," THE DOUG LAWRENCE ORCHESTRA]
[音乐 - "THE WAY YOU LOOK TONIGHT", 道格·劳伦斯管弦乐队]
Act One, What Really Happens in Marriage. OK, here's something that, when you first hear about it, does not sound like it can possibly be true. So let me preface everything you're about to hear by saying that the guy that you're about to hear from is not some isolated crank, but part of a movement, that he and his colleagues, for decades, have been scoring million-dollar grants from the National Institutes of Mental Health. They publish their findings in mainstream scientific journals. Other scientists have replicated their findings. They've essentially created a radically different and eminently helpful way of understanding marriage.
第一幕，婚姻中究竟发生了什么。好的，这里有一件事，当你第一次听说时，听起来简直不可能成真。所以我先说明一下，你们即将听到的这位先生并不是什么孤立的怪人，而是一场运动的一部分，他和他的同事们几十年来一直从美国国立心理健康研究所获得数百万美元的资助。他们在主流科学期刊上发表研究结果。其他科学家也复制了他们的发现。他们实际上创造了一种激进的、非常有用的理解婚姻的方式。
OK, here's what we're talking about. Dr. John Gottman takes couples, wires them up to devices that monitor their breathing and their heartbeats, sits them in front of video cameras, and then asks them to talk about something that they disagree about.
好的，我们讨论的是这个：约翰·戈特曼博士带着夫妻，将他们连接到监测呼吸和心跳的设备上，让他们坐在摄像机前，然后要求他们谈论一件他们有分歧的事情。
From a 15-minute videotape of a couple talking about an area of disagreement, we have an 85% probability of predicting what's going to happen to them in the next four years.
通过一段15分钟的夫妻讨论分歧领域的录像，我们有85%的概率预测他们未来四年的发展情况。
You mean if they'll still be together.
你的意思是他们是否还能在一起。
If they'll still be together or not. And also, if they're together, whether they'll be happy or miserable.
是否在一起，或者分开。如果在一起，他们会幸福还是痛苦。
But that's not all. If he spends another hour or so, and asks them to talk about how they met, what kinds of things they share--
但这还不是全部。如果他再花一个小时左右，让他们谈谈他们是如何相遇的，他们分享了什么——
Then it goes up to 94%.
那么概率会提高到94%。
I should be clear. He doesn't offer this as a service. You can't go to John Gottman, sit with your spouse for a 15-minute videotape, and then have him declare to you on the spot, this will be your marital fate. No. When he says that he can predict, he means it in a more sciencey way. What he does is he videotapes couples, follows their marriages for years, and then once he sees who stays together and who splits up, he goes back and tries to figure out what in the videos might have predicted that. And he has found a whole taxonomy of things that doomed couples do that happy couples don't.
我需要说明清楚。他并不提供这项服务。你不能去找约翰·戈特曼，和配偶坐在一起录制15分钟的视频，然后让他当场宣布你的婚姻命运。不。当他说他能预测时，他的意思是更科学的方式。他所做的是录下夫妻们的视频，跟踪他们的婚姻多年，然后一旦他看到谁在一起、谁分开了，他就会回去分析视频中的什么内容可以预测到这一点。他发现了一整套注定失败的夫妻会做，而幸福的夫妻不会做的事情。
I don't know about you, but when I heard about this, I wanted to understand exactly what Gottman was seeing on those videotapes. And so I went out to visit him in Seattle, to sit with him and watch some of America's unfunniest home videos.
不知道你们怎么样，但当我听说这个时，我想确切地了解戈特曼在那些录像带上看到了什么。于是我前往西雅图拜访他，和他坐在一起观看了美国一些最不有趣的家庭录像。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交谈声]
You might think it would be easy to spot which couples in these videos are heading down the tubes. But in a study where Gottman's videos were shown to clergymen, and therapists, and other people who you would assume would be able to identify this kind of thing, they were unable to predict better than random chance which couples eventually divorced. Take this couple in their early 20s, talking about their finances.
你可能认为很容易看出这些录像中的哪对夫妻正在走向破裂。但在一项研究中，戈特曼的视频被展示给牧师、治疗师和其他你认为能够识别这种事情的人看，结果他们预测的准确率并不比随机猜测好多少，无法判断哪些夫妻最终离婚了。看看这对20岁出头的夫妻，他们在谈论财务问题。
--a month at the most and at the least. Estimate it. Do the math. You don't even sit down and do that.
——一个月最多和最少。估算一下。算一下账。你甚至都不坐下来做这件事。
You don't even sit down and do it either.
你也没坐下来做这件事。
I don't have to. I bring home the money.
我不需要。钱是我赚回来的。
You told me you [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] manage it.
你告诉过我你会 [听不清短语] 管理它。
Well, yeah, to that [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] because I've been asking you to do that.
嗯，是的，对那个 [听不清短语] 因为我一直求你那么做。
Because, [UNINTELLIGIBLE], how can I do it until I-- I need to get the first bill to know what I'm working with.
因为，[听不清]，我怎么能做到直到我——我需要拿到第一张账单才知道我在处理什么。
Watching them, to me, it looks pretty bad. They just don't let up.
看着他们，对我来说，看起来相当糟糕。他们就是不肯放手。
Are they doing good or bad here?
他们这里表现得好还是坏？
Well, I don't see this as a negative interaction. A lot of people might. But we don't see our predictors of divorce here. We don't see contempt. We don't see him turning away, stonewalling, which is a particular guy thing to do. We don't see her insulting him. It could be a lot warmer, it could be a lot more supportive, but they've got to work this out. Newlyweds have a lot of fights. And this is respectful.
嗯，我不认为这是一次负面互动。很多人可能会这么认为。但我们在这里没有看到离婚的预测指标。我们没有看到蔑视。我们没有看到他转过身去、拒绝沟通，这是一种典型的男性做法。我们没有看到她侮辱他。虽然可以更温暖、更支持一些，但他们得解决这个问题。新婚夫妇有很多争吵。而且这是相互尊重的。
You just know what you know, and you block out everything you hear. You just tell me the same thing. Yeah. That's how I feel.
你只是知道你知道的，你屏蔽了你听到的一切。你只是对我重复同样的话。是的。这就是我的感受。
I feel like you do that. I feel like I keep telling you, and you only want to hear what you want to hear. You don't hear the good stuff, like I'm telling you--
我觉得你就是这样。我觉得我一直在告诉你，而你只听你想听的。你听不到好的一面，就像我告诉你——
The way Dr. Gottman turns what look like the most intimate, meandering conversations into hard data that can be analyzed is really pretty simple. After the video is shot, two women in a tiny room down the hall from Dr. Gottman score the thing moment by moment on side-by-side computers. Every time the husband or the wife on the video shows anger, sadness, defensiveness, disgust, humor, neutrality-- any of 20 different things-- it gets coded in the computer alongside data of their heart rate and their breathing.
戈特曼博士将看起来最私密、漫无目的的谈话转变为可以分析的硬数据的过程其实非常简单。视频拍摄后，戈特曼博士办公室走廊尽头一个小房间里的两名女性会对视频进行逐秒编码。每当视频中的丈夫或妻子表现出愤怒、悲伤、防御、厌恶、幽默、中立——任何20种不同事物中的一种时，它就会连同他们的心率和呼吸数据一起输入计算机。
These people have so much affect going on. It's really hard, because you have to make-- you're watching it in real time. You have to make your decision really fast. Is this person being contemptuous? Or wait, was that criticism?
这些人的情感表达太丰富了。这真的很难，因为你必须做出——你是在实时观看。你必须很快做出决定。这个人是在表现蔑视吗？或者等等，那是批评吗？
Elizabeth Schoettle and Katherine Schwartz spent months in training, learning specific facial expressions, particular kinds of behavior, before they became reliable-- reliable meaning in this case that their codes match those of fully-trained people. I asked them to name the codes that they were punching in out loud as they scored one of the videos.
伊丽莎白·肖特尔和凯瑟琳·施瓦茨花了好几个月的时间训练，学习特定的面部表情和特定的行为，然后才变得可靠——在这种情况下，可靠意味着她们的编码与受过完全训练的人的编码相符。我要求她们在为其中一段视频编码时，大声说出她们正在输入的代码。
So I went to contempt, and then I went to neutral. You move back and forth all the time. Now, if you look at his eyes, he's on tension. He finished one of her sentences and sort of helped her along, which would be a high validation.
所以我选择了蔑视，然后选了中立。你总是来回切换。现在，如果你看他的眼睛，他在紧张。他完成了她的一句话并帮了她一把，这将被视为高度认可。
Every momentary interaction-- affection, anger, stonewalling, contempt-- gets assigned a number, one to four for the good ones, negative one to negative four for the bad ones.
每一个瞬间的互动——情感、愤怒、拒绝、蔑视——都会被分配一个数字，好的是一到四，坏的是负一到负四。
So if they do a contempt, they get a minus four. A disgust, the get a minus four. And the computer just keeps track of when they happen and how long they last. So let's watch this conversation.
所以如果他们表现出蔑视，他们得到负四。厌恶，得到负四。计算机只是跟踪这些行为发生的时间和持续时长。让我们来看看这段对话。
Gottman gets another video, and another couple comes up on the TV in black-and-white, split-screen, one camera is on his face, one on hers, a time code in the corner. They're talking about the fact that he is always late.
戈特曼拿来另一段录像，电视上出现了另一对夫妻，黑白画质，分屏，一个镜头对着他的脸，一个对着她的脸，角落里有时间码。他们正在讨论他总是迟到的事实。
I don't believe you. You are really something.
我不相信你。你真是没救了。
It's like--
就像——
It's not funny.
这并不好笑。
Well, you could wake me up.
好吧，你可以叫我起床。
No, I don't want to wake you up. You don't like to hear my voice. It's just like the tone of your mother's. That makes me feel real good, too. You don't like to talk to me.
不，我不想叫你起床。你不喜欢听我的声音。就像你母亲的语气一样。那让我感觉真好。你不喜欢和我说话。
So she's sarcastic and contemptuous. "My tone is just like the sound of your mother. That makes me feel real good, too." That's dripping with contempt, which is one of our best predictors of divorce. She gets a negative score at that instant, that time instant.
所以她是讽刺和轻蔑的。“我的语气就像你母亲的声音。那让我感觉真好。” 这简直是蔑视的化身，这是我们预测离婚的最佳指标之一。她在那个瞬间、那个时间点得到了负分。
Tell me to get up.
告诉我起床。
What am I supposed to say? "Please, get up, dear. Would you get up?"
我该说什么？“求求你，起床吧，亲爱的。你会起床吗？”
Well, if you asked me to. I mean, that's like--
好吧，如果你求我。我是说，那就像——
Get serious.
认真点。
Now, think-- he has a lot of choices here. He can say, "I can see why that would really hurt your feelings, my saying that."
现在，想想——他有很多选择。他可以说，“我能理解为什么我那么说会真正伤害你的感情。”
He could back off. He could de-escalate.
他可以退一步。他可以缓和局势。
Exactly. He could de-escalate. He could hear her pain, which he doesn't.
没错。他可以缓和局势。他可以听到她的痛苦，但他没有。
So when Gottmann and his colleagues make a little graph of all the scores that the man and the woman are getting, as you might imagine, it drops lower and lower and then just never comes back up. Picture a chart in the newspaper of the Dow Jones Industrial Average heading down, and you pretty much have the idea.
所以当戈特曼和他的同事为这对男女得到的所有分数制作一张图表时，正如你所想的那样，分数越来越低，然后就再也没回升过。想象一下报纸上道琼斯工业平均指数下滑的图表，你就大致明白了。
This kind of fight, the kind which gets worse and worse, is one of Gottman's findings for couples heading for divorce. When they argue, it just escalates. They don't take a break, they don't see each other's side, they don't accept influence. That's a phrase that Gottman uses to mean that when one of them says something, it has influence on what the other one is thinking and saying.
这种争吵，这种变得越来越严重的争吵，是戈特曼发现的走向离婚的夫妻的特征之一。当他们争论时，只会升级。他们不休息，他们看不到对方的一面，他们不接受对方的影响。这是戈特曼使用的一个短语，意味着当其中一个人说些什么时，它会对另一个人正在思考和说的话产生影响。
Couples who are in what we call the attack-defend mode, where there's escalating quarrels-- we can actually tell from the first three minutes of their conversation. Most couples will divorce very early, an average of five years after the wedding.
对于那些处于我们所谓的攻击-防御模式，即争吵不断升级的夫妻，我们实际上可以从他们对话的前三分钟看出端倪。大多数夫妻离婚得很早，平均在结婚五年后。
One of these studies had been going on for over a decade when Gottman and his colleagues started noticing a second group of couples from their sample getting divorced. And at first, the researchers could not figure out what was going on.
其中一项研究已经进行了十多年，这时戈特曼和他的同事开始注意到样本中第二组离婚的夫妻。起初，研究人员无法弄清楚发生了什么。
And our predictions were lousy. We couldn't figure out what was wrong with them, at first. Because they seemed fine. They seemed really pretty neutral. They weren't escalating the quarrel. They stayed together. They were fine. Boom, they divorced. 16 years after the wedding, they're divorcing. And then we're going back and saying, wait a minute. Let's look a little more closely.
我们的预测很糟糕。起初，我们弄不明白他们出了什么问题。因为他们看起来很好。他们看起来相当中立。他们没有升级争吵。他们保持在一起。他们挺好的。砰，他们离婚了。结婚16年后，他们离婚了。然后我们回去查看，等等。让我们仔细看一看。
And now you can see that there's no positive emotion really going on that's shared. One of them may laugh. The other one doesn't laugh. One of them looks warm and interested. The other one is pulled away. There's just no fun. They don't seem to enjoy each other at all. Those are the couples where, when you go to a restaurant, you see these couples who aren't talking to each other. That's them. They can last a long time being quite unhappy. They can be great parents. But especially when the kids leave home, they're at risk for really falling apart.
现在你可以看到并没有真正分享什么积极的情绪。一个人可能会笑。另一个人不笑。一个人看起来很温暖和感兴趣。另一个人则退缩了。根本没有乐趣。他们看起来一点也不享受对方。这些就是那种在餐馆里，你看到他们互不交谈的夫妻。那就是他们。他们可以长期保持这种非常不幸福的状态。他们可以是很棒的父母。但特别是当孩子们离家后，他们真的很有可能分崩离析。
Gottman says that when they started this research, they had no idea which factors were going to be the ones that would predict divorce. Nobody had ever observed couples so closely and then followed them over time to see who stayed together and who did not. Therapists and pop psychologists had all kinds of theories as to what would make a good relationship. They were all completely untested.
戈特曼说，当他们开始这项研究时，他们不知道哪些因素会预测离婚。从来没有人如此密切地观察过夫妻，然后随时间跟踪他们，看看谁在一起，谁没有。治疗师和大众心理学家对什么造就一段美好的关系有各种各样的理论。它们完全未经检验。
They thought that having lower expectations of marriage might make for happy marriages. Turns out to be untrue. They thought that good couples make "I" statements instead of "you" statements. Turns out, no. Many people thought-- including Gottman and his colleagues-- that anger would predict divorce. This idea is actually still around, that anger is destructive to any relationship, that it's against the scriptures, that it should be banned from marriages. In fact, the data shows, happy, stable couples get angry all the time.
他们认为对婚姻期望较低可能会促成幸福的婚姻。事实证明并非如此。他们认为优秀的夫妻会使用“我”陈述而不是“你”陈述。事实证明，并非如此。许多人认为——包括戈特曼和他的同事——愤怒会预测离婚。这个想法实际上仍然存在，即愤怒对任何关系都是破坏性的，违背教义，应该被禁止在婚姻之外。事实上，数据表明，幸福、稳定的夫妻总是会生气。
But their partners heard the anger. They responded to it. So a person might say, in a good relationship, "Will you shut up and let me finish?" Really angry, right? And their partner would say, "Alright, finish." Angry response. But then the person got to finish. The anger didn't predict anything negative.
但他们的伴侣听到了愤怒。他们对此做出了回应。所以一个人可能会在一段良好的关系中说：“你能不能闭嘴让我说完？”真的很生气，对吧？而他们的伴侣会说：“好吧，说吧。”愤怒的回应。但之后那个人还是说完了。愤怒并没有预测任何负面的结果。
Now, in a relationship that wasn't working well-- "Will you shut up and let me finish?" "Oh, I don't get to finish until you finish, is that it?" "Yeah." "Why, that's just like what your mother would say?" "Oh, now I'm like my mother, now?" "Yeah, you are. Yadada, yadada, yadada."
现在，在一段运作不佳的关系中——“你能不能闭嘴让我说完？”“噢，我不让你说完你就说不完，是吗？”“是的。”“怎么，这就像你母亲会说的话？”“噢，现在我像我母亲了，是吗？”“是的，你就是。呀哒哒，呀哒哒。”
Contempt. An escalation to defensiveness and contempt. And that's the difference. The anger wasn't predicting anything negative, but the escalation-- that was predicting things negative.
蔑视。升级到防御和蔑视。这就是区别。愤怒并没有预测任何负面结果，但升级——那才是预测负面结果的因素。
Marriage counseling had been around since the end of the second World War. But in a sense, until the 1970s-- until Gottman and this whole generation of researchers-- it was really a pretty ad hoc business. Therapists would give couples all sorts of advice. Sometimes it was useful, sometimes it wasn't. But it wasn't based on scientific research. Until Gottman's generation, nobody had figured out an effective way to observe real marriages-- successful and unsuccessful ones-- and figure out what the happy stable ones were doing that the unhappy divorcing ones weren't.
婚姻咨询从第二次世界大战结束就存在了。但从某种意义上说，直到1970年代——直到戈特曼和这一整代研究人员出现之前——这实际上是一项相当临时的工作。治疗师会给夫妻各种建议。有时有用，有时没用。但它并非基于科学研究。直到戈特曼这一代，还没有人找到一种有效的方法来观察真实的婚姻——成功的和不成功的——并弄清楚幸福稳定的婚姻在做什么，而那些不幸福、离婚的婚姻没有做到什么。
Where we were-- and it's kind of like when we were in the Dark Ages about health care, and we were bleeding patients.
我们当时处于的位置——这有点像我们在医疗保健方面的黑暗时代，当时我们还在给病人放血。
Diane Sollee runs what amounts to the preeminent clearinghouse for marriage research and education, called Smart Marriages in Washington, DC.
戴安·索利在华盛顿特区经营着实际上是婚姻研究和教育的首要信息中心，名为“聪明婚姻”。
And we were basing our premises on old thinking. And then these guys got all these gizmos-- computers, and video cameras, and heart monitors, and all kinds of gizmos-- and they went at it. And so we got real accurate, for the first time, observational research information about what makes marriages succeed or fail.
我们基于旧的思维方式来制定前提。然后这些人得到了所有这些小玩意——电脑、摄像机、心率监测器和各种小玩意——他们开始行动了。于是我们第一次获得了真正准确的、关于婚姻成功或失败原因的观察性研究信息。
One of the most radical findings in the studies is that the studies threw doubt on the idea that couples should split up if they had irreconcilable differences. All couples have irreconcilable differences, the studies proved-- the ones that stay together and the ones that don't.
研究中最激进的发现之一是，这些研究对“如果夫妻有不可调和的分歧就应该分开”的观点提出了质疑。所有夫妻都有不可调和的分歧，研究证明——无论他们是否还在一起。
They found that all couples disagree basically the same amount. And then they thought, well, maybe it's about what they disagree about. And they found, no, it's not that. It's not that some fight about money, and some about sex, and some about-- they found that all couples basically disagree about the same issues.
他们发现所有夫妻争吵的程度基本相同。然后他们想，好吧，也许是因为他们争吵的内容。结果发现，不是。并不是一些人为钱争吵，一些为性争吵，一些为——他们发现所有夫妻基本都在争论同样的问题。
Which are?
哪些？
Money, kids, sex, others, and time. And others are things like who you're jealous of at the office, or your in-laws. And time is like, what are we going to do on Sunday with our leisure time? And so if all couples disagree about the same amount and about the same issues, well, then, what is it? And they found that it was that some couples understand-- they don't go to pieces when they're disagreeing. The success of marriage, they found out, was not based on finding someone with whom you agree on everything, and finding your soul mate. It was how you're going to handle the inevitable disagreements that are going to come up, no matter who you marry.
钱、孩子、性、其他人，以及时间。其他人是指诸如你嫉妒办公室里的谁，或是姻亲之类的事情。时间是指诸如周日我们要在休闲时间做什么？所以如果所有夫妻争吵的程度相同，内容也相同，那么，是什么呢？他们发现是有些夫妻理解——当他们有分歧时，他们不会崩溃。他们发现，婚姻的成功不是基于找到一个你什么都赞同的人，找到你的灵魂伴侣。而是基于你打算如何处理无论你娶谁或嫁给谁都会出现的不可避免的分歧。
OK, so these guys are also talking about the problem of lateness and time. He is always late.
好的，所以这些人也在谈论迟到和时间的问题。他总是迟到。
I guess I'm--
我想我——
I feel kind of like it's dumping on you to discuss--
我感觉讨论你的迟到有点像在找你麻烦——
She's smiling as she says it.
她说这句话时面带微笑。
--your being late.
——你的迟到。
No, I mean that's one of my few weaknesses. I do have some weaknesses.
不，我是说这是我为数不多的弱点之一。我确实有一些弱点。
And he smiles as he says that.
他说这句话时也微笑了。
[? But I don't disagree-- ?]
[？但我并不不同意——？]
There isn't much to argue about.
没什么好争论的。
OK, stop there for a second. Notice how she softened her start up. She didn't say, "I am sick of you being late." She started off by saying, "I feel it's kind of picking on you to start off talking about the lateness and that it's your problem, focusing on you." That's sweet.
好了，先停一下。注意她是怎样软化开场的。她没有说，“我厌倦了你的迟到。”她以说“我觉得开始谈论迟到并把它当作你的问题，关注你，有点像在找你的茬”作为开场。那很贴心。
In fact, the best couples in Gottman's studies-- when they bring up something difficult, they do it in a way that does not make the other person defensive. Even talking about their disagreements, there's laughing. There's joking. This is important because when somebody feels attacked, feels defensive, their heart rate goes up, and basically, Gottman says, reason gets thrown out the window.
事实上，戈特曼研究中最好的夫妻——当他们提出困难的事情时，他们的方式不会让对方感到防御。即使在谈论分歧时，也有笑声。有开玩笑。这一点很重要，因为当一个人感到被攻击、感到防御时，他们的心率会上升，戈特曼说，基本上理智就被抛到九霄云外了。
The heart's beating harder. The arteries start getting constricted and contracted. The body starts secreting adrenaline. And people just can't take in information very well. They can't process information. You can want to be a great listener. Once your heart rate gets above that level, you just can't do it. And you tend to get into what we call the summarizing yourself syndrome. You keep repeating your own ideas over and over again.
心脏跳动得更厉害。动脉开始收缩。身体开始分泌肾上腺素。人们就是无法很好地接收信息。他们无法处理信息。你可能想成为一个很好的倾听者。一旦你的心率超过那个水平，你就做不到了。而且你往往会陷入我们所谓的“自我总结综合症”。你不断地重复自己的观点。
And so when Gottman watches these videos, he's intensely aware of when somebody criticizes and what it does to the other person's pulse. Like here-- this wife tells her husband that a guy that they work with also hates his lateness.
所以当戈特曼观看这些录像时，他敏锐地意识到某人何时进行批评，以及这对他人的脉搏有什么影响。比如这里——这位妻子告诉她的丈夫，他们一起工作的一个人也讨厌他的迟到。
And now I've learned to kind of just expect it and plan around it. Even [UNINTELLIGIBLE] plans around it.
现在我已经学会了去期待它并围绕它做计划。即使 [听不清] 也会围绕它做计划。
Yeah. He isn't as tactful as you are.
是的。他可没你这么圆滑。
No.
不。
They're both laughing.
他们都在笑。
But see then, I can be late but he can't.
但你看，我可以迟到，但他不能。
But you see, I think you're just getting back at your mother for all those times she left you swinging on those swings.
但你看，我觉得你只是在报复你母亲，因为她以前让你在秋千上荡了那么多次。
You know, you may be right.
你知道，你可能是对的。
Here she goes.
她来了。
Yes, and I think you should grow up and not do that.
是的，我认为你应该长大一点，不要那么做。
Now his heart rate is going up.
现在他的心率在上升。
I'm not your mother.
我不是你母亲。
I'm conscious of it, but as you say that--
我意识到了，但当你那么说时——
And watch him start stuttering.
看着他开始结巴。
--the reality of those times when she'd forget about me for hours-- boy. Well, those were very turbulent times for me.
——那些她把我忘了好几个小时的时光确实——天哪。嗯，那对我来说是非常动荡的时期。
See?
看到了吗？
Yeah. God, I hated her for that.
是的。天哪，我那时真恨她。
He's looking down.
他低着头。
The message was very clear. The message was very clear. Boy, life's complex. What about those shoes, anyhow?
信息很清楚。信息非常清楚。天哪，生活真是复杂。不管怎样，那双鞋子怎么样？
These are not fancy shoes. These are old shoes. They're all worn down.
这不是什么时髦的鞋子。这是旧鞋子。它们都磨损了。
No, they're pretty shoes, too. They're nice.
不，它们也是很漂亮的鞋子。它们很好。
Isn't that wonderful? Now, there's a repair. Now a lot of therapists wouldn't consider that a repair.
那不是很好吗？现在，这就是一种修复。很多治疗师不会把那视为修复。
Because he's changing the subject.
因为他在转移话题。
He's changing the subject. A lot of therapists probably would stop this guy and say, hey, wait a minute, we're talking about lateness and your mother. What happened with the shoes? But there-- his heart rate is going down as he's doing that. And she's letting him change the subject and they both laugh about the shoes. And his heart rate goes down. And then they go back to the lateness issue.
他在转移话题。很多治疗师可能会叫停这家伙，说，嘿，等一下，我们正在谈论迟到和你母亲的问题。鞋子怎么了？但在那里——当他这样做时，他的心率正在下降。而她让他转移话题，他们两人都对着鞋子笑了。他的心率下降了。然后他们又回到了迟到的问题上。
As you might expect, after these researchers noticed all these techniques that happy couples use when they disagree, it didn't take long before they started to try to teach those things to the rest of us. They created marriage education courses, which explained how to bring up a difficult subject without completely alienating your partner, how to keep yourself listening when your partner is criticizing you, how to take breaks when things get too hot-- all the stuff that the good couples in the videos do.
正如你可能预料的那样，在这些研究人员注意到幸福夫妻在分歧时使用的所有技巧后，没过多久，他们就开始试图把这些东西教给其他人。他们创建了婚姻教育课程，解释如何提出一个困难的话题而不完全疏远你的伴侣，当你的伴侣批评你时如何保持倾听，当事情变得太激烈时如何休息——所有视频中那些优秀的夫妻所做的事情。
Lots of course like this have sprung up. They generally take just 10 or 12 hours. And Diane Sollee says they get results.
很多这样的课程已经兴起。它们通常只需要10或12个小时。戴安·索利说他们取得了成果。
And we've spent millions of dollars of tax money researching these things. And we know that with a 10-hour class in this marriage education, we can reduce the divorce rate 50% five years out.
我们已经花费了数百万美元的税款来研究这些事情。我们知道，通过一门10小时的婚姻教育课程，我们可以在五年内将离婚率降低50%。
Reducing the divorce rate by 50%-- or really anything at all by 50%-- is the kind of track record that makes policy-makers take notice. And in fact, it is exactly these kinds of marriage education courses that President Bush's $1.5 billion Healthy Marriage Initiative is providing free for welfare recipients. The Army is spending $1.8 million in courses for military families, a program called Building Strong and Ready Families. The courses are also popular in churches. In fact, studies show that couples learn the techniques better if they're taught by their own clergy.
将离婚率降低50%——或者实际上将任何事物降低50%——是那种让政策制定者注意到的成绩。事实上，布什总统15亿美元的“健康婚姻倡议”正在为福利领取者免费提供这类婚姻教育课程。军队正在为军人家庭花费180万美元进行课程，这是一个名为“建立强大且准备就绪的家庭”的项目。这些课程在教堂里也很受欢迎。事实上，研究表明，如果夫妻由他们自己的牧师来教，他们学习技巧的效果会更好。
Some researchers say that this new interest and investment is great, but they caution that while Gottman's study and most of the other marriage studies get interesting results, they're still relatively small as research goes-- anywhere from 30 to 300 couples usually, small enough that you can get random results that really might not have much meaning. One researcher told me that it's not like science has killer airtight conclusions about marriage yet. It's more like we have decent preliminary findings, and the main reason these courses and government programs exist is not that the science is perfect, but that people want answers. They want answers now. They want help. And it seemed like we knew enough to act.
一些研究人员表示，这种新的兴趣和投资很棒，但他们告诫说，虽然戈特曼的研究和大多数其他婚姻研究得到了有趣的结果，但作为研究而言，它们仍然相对较小——通常从30到300对夫妻不等，小到你可能会得到一些可能没太大意义的随机结果。一位研究人员告诉我，这不像科学对婚姻已经有了致命的、无懈可击的结论。更像是我们有了体面的初步发现，而这些课程和政府项目存在的主要原因不是科学是完美的，而是人们需要答案。他们现在就需要答案。他们需要帮助。而且看起来我们掌握的知识足以采取行动。
Gottman and a researcher named Bob Levenson have also done a 12-year study of homosexual couples. There were just 42 couples-- a small study for Gottman, who usually gets 130 couples of races and ages to match the demographics of Seattle.
戈特曼和一位名叫鲍勃·莱文森的研究员还对同性恋伴侣进行了一项为期12年的研究。只有42对伴侣——对于通常从西雅图的种族和年龄人口统计中选取130对伴侣的戈特曼来说，这是一个小规模的研究。
In fact, we've just submitted a research grant application to do that study over again with a larger sample size where we would try to get representative sampling. It's just that it's hard to get funded to do research on gay and lesbian relationships. The government is really not positively disposed to doing that research, and in fact, if you say "gay and lesbian" it will be pulled. It won't even be reviewed by the government. It will get pulled. There are these watchdog organizations.
事实上，我们刚刚提交了一份研究拨款申请，要求再次进行那项研究，并扩大样本量，我们将尝试进行代表性抽样。只是很难获得资金来进行同性恋关系的研究。政府对进行这项研究并没有积极的态度，事实上，如果你说“同性恋”这个词，它就会被撤下。它甚至不会被政府审查。它会被撤下。有这些监督机构。
So how do you say it?
那你怎么说呢？
You talk about commitment in same-sex relationships.
你谈论同性关系中的承诺。
But why wouldn't they just notice that same-sex means the same thing?
但为什么他们不注意到同性意味着同样的事情呢？
It turns out they have these computer programs that scan the abstracts for keywords.
事实证明，他们有这些电脑程序会扫描摘要中的关键词。
I see.
我明白了。
And if you don't use those keywords, then they don't get picked up.
如果你不使用这些关键词，那么它们就不会被提取。
Well, I hope I'm not blowing your cover here by broadcasting this.
嗯，我希望我没有通过广播这件事来暴露你的掩护。
Well, that's the kind of climate in which we're working.
嗯，这就是我们工作的环境。
The study looked at 21 lesbian couples and 21 gay male couples, and compared them to 42 straight marriages of the same length of relationship and relationship satisfaction, as measured on a questionnaire. The researchers videotaped the couples talking about some issue that they conflict about. And they found that the homosexual couples were far better than the married heterosexual couples at bringing up an issue in a non-confrontational way, of listening when criticized. They were less defensive. They were more positive.
这项研究观察了21对女同性恋伴侣和21对男同性恋伴侣，并将他们与42对关系长度和关系满意度（通过问卷测量）相同的异性恋婚姻进行了比较。研究人员录下了夫妻谈论他们有冲突的问题的视频。他们发现，同性恋伴侣在以非对抗性的方式提出问题、在被批评时倾听方面，远比已婚的异性恋夫妻做得好。他们防御性较弱。他们更积极。
The other thing we were able to do with our mathematical modeling was to find that not only do they start differently, but also the influence process in the married couple really moves them toward a more negative direction. The longer they talk to each other, the more angry they get, the more adversarial they tend to get. But in gay and lesbian couples, it's the opposite. The longer they talk about the issue, the closer they get and the more positive they become. So a very, very different process operating in the gay and lesbian couples we studied.
我们能够通过数学建模做的另一件事是发现，他们不仅开始的方式不同，而且已婚夫妇的影响过程确实将他们推向了更消极的方向。他们交谈的时间越长，他们就越愤怒，他们往往就越敌对。但在男同和女同伴侣中，情况恰恰相反。他们谈论问题的时间越长，他们就越亲近，他们就变得越积极。所以在我们研究的同性恋伴侣中，运作着一个非常、非常不同的过程。
Now if they're representative, then we heterosexuals have got a lot to learn from gay and lesbian relationships.
现在，如果他们具有代表性，那么我们这些异性恋者就有很多东西要向同性恋关系学习了。
But John, the gay couples and the lesbian couples that you're talking about-- they're simply as good as the very best couples in your heterosexual couples? Or you're saying they're even better than them?
但约翰，你谈论的这些男同和女同伴侣——他们仅仅和你的异性恋伴侣中最好的那些一样好？还是你说他们甚至比那些人更好？
They're even better than them.
他们甚至比那些人更好。
Really?
真的吗？
I mean, when you listen to the tapes, it's unbelievable what they're like. I'll give you an example of this. One gay man said to his partner, "What did you think about the sex this morning? Who do you think initiated the sex this morning?" And his partner said, "Well, you don't really have the kind of body on a man that I find really the most attractive." And the first man said, "I know that. But who do you think initiated sex this morning?"
我是说，当你听录像带时，他们表现出的样子简直令人难以置信。我给你举个例子。一位男同性恋者对他的伴侣说：“你觉得今天早上的性生活怎么样？你觉得今天早上是谁主动的？” 他的伴侣说：“嗯，你的身材并没有让我觉得非常有吸引力。” 第一个男人说：“我知道。但你觉得今天早上是谁主动的？”
Now can you imagine a husband--
现在你能想象一个丈夫——
Oh, my God.
天哪。
--talking to his wife, right?
——和他的妻子谈话，对吧？
And saying, "You don't have the kind of body that I find attractive."
并且说，“你的身材并没有让我觉得有吸引力。”
That's right. Can you imagine her saying, "Yeah, I know that. But who do you think initiated sex?" So there's so much less deception, so much more honesty, and so much more directness. And I don't know if it's representative. But I was very impressed.
没错。你能想象她说，“是的，我知道。但你觉得是谁主动的？” 所以欺骗要少得多，诚实和直接要多得多。我不知道这是否具有代表性。但我印象非常深刻。
Gottman still can't explain why the gay couples would be so different. He thinks part of the reason might be that, in general, it's just easier for men to talk to men and women to talk to women. The fact that they communicate so differently makes things harder in heterosexual couples.
戈特曼仍然无法解释为什么同性恋伴侣会有如此大的不同。他认为部分原因可能是，总的来说，男人与男人交谈，女人与女人交谈只是更容易一些。他们沟通方式的不同使得异性恋伴侣的情况变得更加困难。
Back when I started calling around to marriage researchers, I expected that as a group they would be people who think a lot about our country's 50% divorce rate, like the divorce rate is the Mount Everest that they're all aiming at not just assaulting, but ultimately blasting down into rubble. But in fact, every researcher I called was reluctant to speculate about what all this new research could mean for the divorce rate someday. Could they get it down to 30%? Or maybe 10%? It's just too early to know, they would say.
当初我开始打电话给婚姻研究人员时，我以为作为一个群体，他们会是那些对我们国家50%的离婚率想得很多的人，就好像离婚率是他们都瞄准的珠穆朗玛峰，不仅要冲击它，还要最终把它炸成瓦砾。但实际上，我打给的每一位研究人员都不愿推测所有这些新研究未来对离婚率意味着什么。他们能把它降到30%吗？或者也许10%？他们会说，现在知道还为时过早。
After some prodding, I did get Gottman to tell me that a significant portion, 15% to 20% of the troubled couples in one of his studies probably were people who should be divorced. Even before their marriages, he said, they never had a basic rapport where they could spend time together easily and comfortably, where conversation just flowed. For everything this research shows about how people can prevent divorce, for everything that it shows about how much happier couples can be if they master certain communication skills, for everything that he can quantify with his video cameras and his heart monitors, in the end, John Gottman still believes in chemistry.
在一番催促下，我确实让戈特曼告诉我，他研究中有一部分陷入困境的夫妻，即15%到20%，可能确实是应该离婚的人。他说，甚至在他们结婚之前，他们就从未建立过一种基本的默契，即他们可以轻松舒适地共度时光，对话可以顺畅流动。尽管这项研究展示了人们如何预防离婚，尽管它展示了如果掌握了某些沟通技巧，夫妻可以过得多么幸福，尽管他可以用摄像机和心率监测器量化一切，但最终，约翰·戈特曼仍然相信化学反应。
[MUSIC - "BRICK HOUSE," THE DOUG LAWRENCE ORCHESTRA]
[音乐 - "BRICK HOUSE", 道格·劳伦斯管弦乐队]
See, that's a wedding band. Coming up, it's raining lawsuits. A look inside them-- that's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
看，那才叫婚礼乐队。接下来，诉讼如雨。深入了解它们——再过一分钟，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program-- The Sanctity of Marriage, stories about what that might mean. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, The Defense of Marriage Act. When the White House proposed the constitutional amendment preventing gay marriage, the president explained why it was necessary this way. He said, marriage is a sacred institution between a man and a woman. If activist judges insist on redefining marriage by court order, the only alternative will be the constitutional process. We must do what is legally necessary to defend the sanctity of marriage.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，并为您带来关于该主题的各种不同类型的故事。今天的节目——“婚姻的神圣性”，关于那可能意味着什么的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，《捍卫婚姻法案》。当白宫提议修改宪法以防止同性婚姻时，总统解释了为什么它是必要的。他说，婚姻是男人和女人之间神圣的制度。如果激进的法官坚持通过法院命令重新定义婚姻，唯一的选择就是宪法程序。我们必须做法律上必要的事情来捍卫婚姻的神圣性。
Well, Adam Felber says he knows just what the president is talking about.
嗯，亚当·费尔伯说他知道总统在说什么。
This gay marriage thing is tearing my wife and me apart. Because of activist judges in Massachusetts and overzealous officials in San Francisco, our union is hanging on by the thinnest of threads. Are Jeannie and I expected to treasure our union solely on the basis of our deep love, personal beliefs, public vows, and the government's blessing? Sorry, Judge Pinkypants, but that's just not good enough, not for us. We need to know that we've got something that's only available to 90% of the population.
这个同性婚姻的事正在把我和我妻子拆散。因为马萨诸塞州的激进法官和旧金山那些热心的官员，我们的结合正悬在一根极细的线上。我和珍妮是不是只能基于我们深沉的爱、个人信仰、公开的誓言和政府的祝福来珍视我们的结合？抱歉，粉色底裤法官（Judge Pinkypants），但这还不够，对我们来说不够。我们需要知道，我们拥有的东西只有90%的人口才能拥有。
Sure, some of us are criminals, murderers even. Some of us have committed rape, beaten children, tattooed swastikas on our bodies, abused animals, bilked the government out of millions of tax dollars, lied under oath, cheated on previous spouses, dishonored our fathers and mothers, failed to keep the Sabbath holy, mowed down pedestrians in our SUVs while intoxicated, coveted our neighbor's stuff, gotten ourselves put on death row, sold military secrets to the Chinese, urinated in public places, beaten up people who looked or sounded different than us, but we're straight. And that means we can get married. And that's special. Or at least it was.
当然，我们中的一些人是罪犯，甚至是杀人犯。我们中的一些人犯过强奸罪，虐待过孩子，身上纹过纳粹党徽，虐待过动物，从政府那里骗取了数百万美元的税款，在宣誓下撒过谎，背叛过前配偶，羞辱过我们的父母，未能守安息日，酒后驾驶 SUV 撞倒过行人，贪图邻居的东西，让自己进了死囚牢，把军事秘密卖给中国人，在公共场所随地大小便，殴打过看起来或听起来与我们不同的人，但我们是异性恋者。这意味着我们可以结婚。而且那很特别。或者至少过去是这样。
Are some gay people serious about their commitment to each other? Sure, of course. That's not the point. Let me give you an example. Jeannie and I know this couple, these two men. They've been together for years and years, longer than we have. They live on a farm in Pennsylvania and treasure their time together. They are loved by their community, have saved lives as members of the local fire department, and have opened their home to youth groups from the city. They've built a life together based on love and trust. But-- and here's my point-- they're gay. They're both men. And if they're allowed to marry someday, where does that leave us, my wife and me? See what I'm saying? It would cheapen everything we have.
有些同性恋者对彼此的承诺是认真的吗？当然，当然。那不是重点。让我给你举个例子。珍妮和我认识一对伴侣，两个男人。他们在一起已经很多年很多年了，比我们还要久。他们住在宾夕法尼亚州的一个农场里，珍视他们共度的时光。他们深受社区喜爱，作为当地消防部门的成员挽救过生命，并向来自城市的青年团体开放了他们的家。他们基于爱和信任共同建立了一个生活。但是——我的观点是——他们是同性恋。他们都是男人。如果有一天允许他们结婚，那我和我妻子怎么办？明白我的意思吗？这会贬低我们拥有的一切。
That's why we need a constitutional amendment that will protect marriage for straight people. Unless we have the right to enter that sacred union, violate it, exit it, and enter it again with somebody else over and over, regardless of what crimes we commit-- unless we have that right and gay people don't, then there truly is nothing sacred in the United States of America.
这就是为什么我们需要一个保护异性恋婚姻的宪法修正案。除非我们有权利进入那个神圣的结合，违反它，退出它，并再次与其他人进入它，一遍又一遍，无论我们犯了什么罪——除非我们有那个权利而同性恋者没有，那么美利坚合众国就真的没有什么神圣可言了。
Adam Felber is a writer in New York, sometimes heard on the radio program Wait Wait... Don't Tell Me! His website, where this first appeared, felbers.net.
亚当·费尔伯是纽约的一位作家，有时会在广播节目《等一下……别告诉我！》中听到他的声音。他的网站，也就是这篇文章首次出现的地方，felbers.net。
The opponents of gay marriage are vigorously pushing for state and federal constitutional amendments. And they are fighting in court. But sometimes it seems like they're in kind of a funny position. I don't know if you saw this. I saw them on Larry King the night that the president called for a constitutional amendment last year. And they were on there talking about the Bible, and quoting scripture, and saying that homosexuality is just wrong, that it's a values question. Not for everybody, but for lots of opponents of gay marriage, they think that gays just should not be such a big part of mainstream America.
同性婚姻的反对者正在积极推动州和联邦的宪法修正案。他们也在法庭上抗争。但有时看起来他们处在一种有点滑稽的境地。我不知道你是否看到了。总统去年呼吁修改宪法的那天晚上，我在拉里·金的节目上看到了他们。他们在那里谈论圣经，引用经文，并说同性恋就是错误的，这是一个价值观问题。不是对每个人，但对许多同性婚姻的反对者来说，他们认为同性恋者不应该成为美国主流社会的重要组成部分。
And the problem is, you can't really argue that in court-- not in this day and age-- not and expect to get very far, anyway. And so we asked Matt Staver, who runs the Liberty Counsel and goes into court for them-- they're the group opposing gay marriage that went into court in California-- to briefly explain to us what arguments he is actually using in court, the legal arguments to defend a traditional marriage clause.
问题是，你在法庭上无法真正争辩这一点——在这个时代——无论如何，别指望能走多远。所以我们请马特·斯塔弗，他经营着“自由顾问”（Liberty Counsel）并为他们出庭——他们是在法庭上反对同性婚姻的团体，并去了加州的法庭——让他简要地向我们解释他在法庭上实际使用的论点，即捍卫传统婚姻条款的法律论点。
The defense would be several-fold. Number one, it would look at the marriage laws and ask the question whether or not the government of that particular state has a rational reason, or a rational basis, for classifying marriage between one man and one woman. So if the court can find what it calls a rational basis, then the law is ultimately upheld. You break that down in several ways. Number one, you can look at children.
辩护是多方面的。第一，它会审视婚姻法，并提出政府在特定州是否有理性的理由或理性基础，将婚姻分类为一男一女。所以如果法院能找到它所称的理性基础，那么法律最终就会得到支持。你可以通过几种方式分解它。第一，你可以看看孩子。
We already know, for example, from many studies, that children do best when they're raised in a home with a mother and father. So the state could certainly have a rational basis for instituting marriage between one man and one woman to protect children. Now, that may be debatable. But the question is not whether it's debatable or not. It's whether or not the state has a rational purpose, even though it's debatable. As long as it's reasonable or rational, that's enough to uphold the state marriage law.
我们已经知道，例如，从许多研究中，孩子们在由父母双方抚养的家庭中成长得最好。因此，州政府当然可以有一个理性基础来建立一男一女之间的婚姻，以保护孩子。嗯，这可能是有争议的。但问题不在于它是否有争议。而在于州政府是否有合理的目的，即使它有争议。只要它是合理的，这就足以支持州婚姻法。
In a way, the power of that comes from the fact that-- let's say the other side has their studies which argue one thing, and you guys have your studies that argue something else. You're saying, as long as your side is defendable, you win.
从某种程度上说，这种力量来自于——假设对方有他们的研究来支持某一点，而你们有你们的研究来支持另一点。你是在说，只要你们那方是可以辩护的，你们就赢了。
That's exactly right.
完全正确。
In Massachusetts, the problem for people like Matt Staver who oppose gay marriage is that the court said, no, there is not even a reasonable case to be made. There is not a rational basis for the state to give preference to male-female couples in raising children. And the court did this in a kind of interesting way. They said, essentially, our hands are tied. We are bound by our own precedents and by laws that the legislature has passed. Under Massachusetts law, gay adoption is just as good as heterosexual adoption. Gays are equal to straights in custody cases. There is a network of vigorous gender-neutral laws that have already settled this question, and settled it by saying that in Massachusetts, gays are equal parents to straights. So the opponents of gay marriage have even started to lose this test of reasonableness.
在马萨诸塞州，像马特·斯塔弗这样反对同性婚姻的人面临的问题是，法院说，不，根本没有合理的理由。州政府在抚养孩子方面给予男女伴侣优先权，并没有理性基础。法院以一种有趣的方式做到了这一点。他们本质上说，我们的双手被束缚了。我们受到自己先例和立法机构通过的法律的约束。根据马萨诸塞州法律，同性收养和异性恋收养一样好。同性恋者在监护权案件中与异性恋者平等。已经存在一个强有力的性别中立法律网络，这些法律已经解决了这个问题，并将其解决为在马萨诸塞州，同性恋者与异性恋者是平等的父母。所以同性婚姻的反对者甚至开始在这个合理性的考验中落败。
The other problem for opponents of gay marriage is that a couple of state courts-- Alaska and Hawaii-- have said that keeping gays from marrying is the most serious kind of discrimination, just as serious as race or gender discrimination. Now, from Matt Staver's perspective, this is an outrageous kind of judicial activism, and here's why.
同性婚姻反对者面临的另一个问题是，几个州法院——阿拉斯加和夏威夷——已经表示，阻止同性恋者结婚是最严重的歧视，与种族或性别歧视一样严重。现在，从马特·斯塔弗的角度来看，这是一种令人发指的司法能动主义，原因如下。
Homosexuality has never been considered a class by any court in the country, such that it actually comes under the equal protection clause. You have to be considered a class. And one of the ways to be considered a class is to be a distinct group that has immutable characteristics like, for example, race-- that's an identifiable group-- and gender-- that's an identifiable group.
同性恋从未被国内任何法院视为一个阶级，以至于它实际上属于平等保护条款的范畴。你必须被视为一个阶级。被视为阶级的方法之一是成为一个拥有不可变特征的独特群体，例如，种族——那是一个可识别的群体——以及性别——那也是一个可识别的群体。
Homosexuals may see themselves as a distinct group with immutable characteristics, but the courts haven't seen them that way in the past. Then Oregon ruled otherwise in 1998. And now that states are shifting on both the big questions like this one and some of the smaller questions, Matt Staver's job has gotten a lot harder. None of the arguments available to him is a slam dunk anymore, like they were in the 1970s.
同性恋者可能认为自己是一个拥有不可变特征的独特群体，但法院过去并没有那样看待他们。然后俄勒冈州在1998年做出了不同的裁决。现在各州在这一类大问题和一些较小的问题上都在发生转变，马特·斯塔弗的工作变得困难多了。他能使用的论点都不再是那种必胜的扣篮了，就像他们在1970年代那样。
David Cruz is a law professor at the University of Southern California who follows and writes about these issues.
大卫·克鲁兹是南加州大学的一名法学教授，他追踪并撰写关于这些议题的文章。
If they get an occasionally sympathetic judge, they might win a victory. But if they want to make sure that you don't start seeing marriage in state after state, then they need to do something blunt and dramatic. That's why they're asking the nation to amend the constitution, because the arguments for keeping marriage to just a man and a woman are too weak. It's like changing the rules of the game. If you can't win making the arguments that are currently allowed under our constitution, they have to try to change the constitution to just eliminate the need for argument, and just on the face of it say, well, marriage just is this way.
如果他们偶尔能遇到一位同情的法官，他们可能会赢得胜利。但如果他们想确保你不会在各个州开始看到婚姻（同性婚姻），那么他们需要采取一些迟钝而戏剧性的行动。这就是为什么他们要求全国修改宪法，因为将婚姻仅限于一男一女的论点太软弱了。这就像改变游戏规则。如果你不能通过我们宪法目前允许的论点获胜，他们就必须尝试修改宪法以消除对论点的需要，并仅仅在表面上说，好吧，婚姻就是这样。
Hence the push for a constitutional amendment. 13 states banned gay marriage in their state constitutions this fall. And another 18 are considering it.
因此推动宪法修正案。今年秋天，13个州在州宪法中禁止了同性婚姻。还有18个州正在考虑这样做。
[MUSIC - "COPACABANA," THE DOUG LAWRENCE ORCHESTRA]
[音乐 - "COPACABANA", 道格·劳伦斯管弦乐队]
Act Three, I Want to Be a Statistic. Well, John Gottman may videotape couples as they argue, but nobody observes marriage better than a couple's own kids. Starlee Kine has this story about what marriages stay together and which ones break up, and about her parents' vision of marriage back in southern California.
第三幕，我想成为一个统计数据。嗯，约翰·戈特曼可能会在夫妻争吵时录下录像，但没有人比夫妻自己的孩子观察婚姻观察得更好。斯塔莉·凯恩带来了这个关于哪些婚姻能维持、哪些会破裂的故事，以及关于她父母在南加州对婚姻的看法。
About three months ago, I received a postcard in the mail. On the front was a picture of a kitten staring out at me with big watery eyes. On the back was scrawled a handwritten note. "Dear Starlee, divorced and loving it. Love, Mom. "
大约三个月前，我收到了一张明信片。正面是一只小猫瞪着大大的水汪汪的眼睛看着我。背面潦草地写着一张手写便条。“亲爱的斯塔莉，离婚了，并且很享受。爱你的，妈妈。”
My parents filed for divorce this past November. They had been unhappily married for 31 years. My earliest childhood memory is from when I was four years old. My family took a road trip to Oregon. I was sitting in the back next my older sister. My dad was pointing out the window at the trees saying something along the lines of, "Wow, these trees are really something. They're just so tall."
我父母在去年11月提出了离婚。他们在这段不幸福的婚姻中度过了31年。我最早的童年记忆是在我四岁的时候。我们全家去俄勒冈州公路旅行。我坐在后座，挨着我姐姐。我爸爸指着窗外的树说了一些类似于，“哇，这些树真的很壮观。它们长得真高。”
My mom whipped her head around, her eyes already in mid-roll. "For God's sake, Norm. They're not that tall." Then both my parents let out a long sigh.
我妈妈猛地转过头，眼睛已经翻到了半空中。“看在上帝的份上，诺姆。它们没那么高。” 然后我父母都发出了长长的叹息。
It was at that moment that I can remember having a thought, maybe the first original thought I ever had. I recall looking up at my parents and thinking, "Well, this just isn't going to work."
就是在那个时刻，我记得产生了一个念头，也许是我有过的第一个原创想法。我记得抬头看着我父母，心想，“嗯，这根本行不通。”
If we switched, sooner or later, they'd have to unswitch us.
如果我们换过来，迟早他们得把我们换回去。
Mother would have to bring me to California to unmix us.
妈妈得把我带到加州把我们分开。
And they'd have to meet again.
他们得再见一次面。
Face to face. Are you thinking what I'm thinking?
面对面。你在想我想的吗？
Exactly.
没错。
Let's get to work.
开始工作吧。
I watched The Parent Trap all the time when I was a kid. It became a bit of an obsession. I regarded the plan the twin sisters came up with as a blueprint for how to deal with my own family, with one minor change. While the twins in the movie wanted to get their parents back together, I wanted to break mine apart. I'd watch the movie and try to notice how it was done.
我小时候一直看《天生一对》（The Parent Trap）。它变成了一种迷恋。我把那对双胞胎姐妹想出来的计划视为如何处理我家庭的一个蓝图，只有一个小改动。电影里的双胞胎想让父母重归于好，而我想让我的父母分手。我会看那部电影，并试图注意它是怎么做的。
It was like following directions somewhere, and then just doing the opposite to get back home. Where you turned right before, you now turned left. Where you turned left, you now turned right. Instead of tricking my parents into being in the same room, my sister and I would schedule my tap and her drum lessons at the same time, so only one of our parents would be able to pick each of us up.
这就像是顺着路线走，然后做相反的事情回到家。你之前右转，现在左转。你之前左转，现在右转。我和姐姐不仅不欺骗父母让他们待在同一个房间里，反而会把我的踢踏舞课和她的鼓课安排在同一时间，这样我父母每次只能有一个人接我们。
And really, it didn't seem like breaking my parents up was something that should be that hard to do. They fought constantly. For my mom, everything about my dad seemed to irritate her-- the way he ate, the way he slept, even the way his feet were extra long so he had to wear specially sized shoes. All the stories she told of my childhood ended the same way. "I brought you home from the hospital. You were such a beautiful baby. And then your father carried the bags in and forgot to shut the front door. I remember it like it was yesterday."
而且说实话，让我的父母分手似乎不应该那么难。他们经常吵架。对于我妈妈来说，关于我爸爸的一切似乎都让她恼火——他吃饭的方式、他睡觉的方式，甚至他脚特别大以至于不得不穿特制尺寸鞋子的方式。她讲述的所有关于我童年的故事最后都一样。“我把你从医院带回家。你是个那么漂亮的孩子。然后你父亲把包拿进来，忘了关前门。我记得就像昨天发生的一样。”
My dad responded to my mom's irritation by withdrawing more and more from our family. Every day without fail, as soon as he got home from work, he'd get on the phone and talk for hours and hours. At first, they were just regular business calls to his associates. The conversations would be all about work. But then, as the hour grew later, he'd start asking about their kids, about what they were having for dinner that night or their plan for the weekend. He seemed more comfortable taking an interest in the lives of other people's families than in ours. I used to joke to my friends that half the time, my dad wasn't even talking to anyone at all, that if we were to go upstairs and pick up the extension, we'd hear nothing but silence from the other end.
我爸爸通过从我们家庭中撤退得越来越多来回应我妈妈的恼火。每天毫无例外，他一下班回家，就会打电话并一聊就是好几个小时。起初，那只是给同事的普通公务电话。谈话内容全是工作。但后来，随着时间越来越晚，他开始询问他们的孩子，询问他们晚上吃什么或者周末的计划。他似乎更乐于对别人的家庭生活感兴趣，而不是我们的。我过去常开玩笑说，有一半的时间，我爸爸根本没在跟任何人说话，如果我们上楼拿起分机，我们会听到另一端只有沉默。
For years, the biggest mystery in my life was how these two people ever managed to end up together. But over time, that question was trumped by a much bigger one, why they decided to stay together for so long. I can't really get the answer from my mom because, to put it mildly, she's a little off-kilter. She's never been officially diagnosed with anything, but even so, she does a lot of things outside the realm of normal people. And over the years, her behavior has become much more extreme. So that leaves my dad.
多年来，我生命中最大的谜团是这两个人是怎么走到一起的。但随着时间的推移，那个问题被一个更大的问题所取代：为什么他们决定在一起这么久。我无法从我妈妈那里得到答案，因为委婉地说，她有点不正常。她从未被正式诊断出什么，但即便如此，她还是做了很多超出正常人范围的事情。而且多年来，她的行为变得更加极端。所以那留下了我爸爸。
All my life, I have urged my dad to leave my mom, to free himself of all the unhappiness, and yelling, and erratic behavior. But not only has my dad refused to end the marriage, he's refused to even acknowledge they had any problems. It wasn't until after the divorce finally went through this year that my dad was able to gain any perspective on his marriage. My dad agreed to talk to me on tape to try and explain to me why he and my mom stayed together.
我一生中都敦促爸爸离开妈妈，从所有的不快乐、咆哮和古怪行为中解放自己。但不仅我爸爸拒绝结束婚姻，他甚至拒绝承认他们有任何问题。直到今年离婚最终通过后，我爸爸才对他的婚姻获得了一些看法。我爸爸同意在录音带上和我交谈，试图向我解释为什么他和妈妈待在一起。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hello?
喂？
Dad?
爸爸？
Hi, Starlee.
嗨，斯塔莉。
I start off by asking him if there was ever a good time in their relationship, or was it really always as bad as I remembered it?
我开始问他，他们的关系中是否有过美好的时光，还是真的像我记得的那样一直都很糟糕？
It was always rocky from the start. I don't remember.
从一开始就一直很艰难。我不记得了。
You don't remember. Did it ever feel right, though? You and Mom?
你不记得了。但感觉对过吗？你和妈妈？
I have-- I don't know.
我有——我不知道。
I mean, from my perspective, it never seemed right. I mean, it's a different perspective. But from what I've always witnessed-- from a very, very, very young age-- it never seemed like you guys were right for each other ever. I remember lots of times when I was a kid, running into your office and trying to tell you to get a divorce. Do you remember any of that time?
我是说，从我的角度来看，它从未感觉对过。我的意思是，这是一个不同的视角。但从我一直目睹的一切来看——从非常非常小的时候开始——你们似乎从来不适合彼此。我记得小时候好多次，跑进你的办公室试图告诉你离婚。你记得那段时光吗？
I don't recall that at all.
我一点都不记得了。
Really? Because it wasn't a mystery to us that you guys had problems, obviously.
真的吗？因为你们有问题对我们来说不是什么秘密，显然。
Well, people who I knew that I had not seen until recently have all-- many of them have made the remark that they felt that your mother was very hard to live with.
嗯，我认识的人，直到最近才见到的人，都——他们中的许多人都评论说他们觉得你妈妈非常难相处。
Yeah, I'll say.
是的，我会说的。
Why they would even know that or say that, I don't know because--
为什么他们会知道或说那样的话，我不知道，因为——
Mom had a lot of outbursts around Whittier. Like, lots of fights and craziness. Remember when she tried to buy the house without telling you?
妈妈在惠蒂尔附近有很多爆发。比如，很多的争吵和疯狂行为。记得她试图瞒着你不买房子的事吗？
Oh, I remember that. Yeah.
噢，我记得那个。是的。
What happened there? What happened when she tried to buy the house without telling you?
那里发生了什么？当她试图瞒着你不买房子时发生了什么？
She forged my name. And then the people sued us. And they got a judgment against her. They couldn't get it against me, because I had no knowledge of it.
她伪造了我的名字。然后人们起诉了我们。他们对她做出了判决。他们不能针对我，因为我对此一无所知。
What was she planning to do with that house? Was she going to tell you that you guys were going to move?
她打算用那栋房子做什么？她是不是要告诉你你们要搬家？
Yeah, she told me on the last day. She said, this is the house we're buying. I said, number one, we can't afford it. Number two, it's ugly.
是的，她在最后一天告诉了我。她说，这就是我们要买的房子。我说，第一，我们买不起。第二，它很丑。
And that is not a good sign of a healthy marriage.
那不是健康婚姻的好迹象。
That's true. Not a sign of a healthy relationship. That's right.
那是真的。不是健康关系的迹象。没错。
No. So how did you feel when she did that?
不。那你妈妈那样做时你感觉如何？
How did I feel? I wasn't very happy about it.
我感觉如何？我对此并不怎么高兴。
No. But you stuck with it.
不。但你坚持下来了。
Yeah.
是的。
Why?
为什么？
I just did.
我只是坚持了。
Why?
为什么？
Y is a crooked letter.
“Y”是个歪曲的字母。（这是一句英语谚语，意为“不要追问，没有明确理由”。）
My dad has always been fond of this answer. Sometimes he likes to mix it up with a, "the grass is always greener" or a "you can't fit a square peg in a round hole." But this one was always a keeper. And as I got older and started asking him all the time why he stayed in such a miserable marriage, my frustration would just grow stronger with each "Y is a crooked letter" answer he gave, especially as my mom's antics became more and more pronounced.
我爸爸一直喜欢这个答案。有时他喜欢混入“草总是绿的”或者“你不能把方钉放进圆孔里”。但这个总是保留着的。随着我长大并开始一直问他为什么待在这么悲惨的婚姻里，我的挫败感随着他给出的每一个“Y是个歪曲的字母”的回答而增长，尤其是在我妈妈的行为变得越来越明显的时候。
Or as, for example, the day my mom finally took my dad to court, although it wasn't for the reason I'd always hoped it would be.
或者，比如，我妈妈终于把我爸爸告上法庭的那天，尽管那并不是我一直希望的那样。
My dad was born Norman [? Slobodkin. ?] For the first few years of my life, that my last name too. Starlee [? Candy ?] [? Slobodkin. ?] Yes, it was hard to spell and clunky to say. But I could live with it. My mom, on the other hand, could not. In her mind, his name was the only thing that stood between us and a world of endless possibility. She held the [? Slobodkin ?] name personally responsible for all her problems. She'd lie on the couch, a hot towel pressed to her temples, and marvel at how her life had ended up this way. "How will I ever be a diplomat's wife now, with a name like that? And I can forget about First Lady. President [? Slobodkin? ?] Please. The press would eat us alive."
我爸爸出生时叫诺曼·斯洛博德金（Slobodkin）。在我生命的前几年，那也是我的姓。斯塔莉·坎迪·斯洛博德金。是的，它很难拼写，说起来也很拗口。但我可以接受。然而，我妈妈不能。在她心里，他的名字是阻挡在我们和充满无限可能的日子之间的唯一障碍。她认为斯洛博德金这个名字要对她所有的问题负个人责任。她会躺在沙发上，用热毛巾压着太阳穴，感叹她的人生怎么会变成这样。“有着那样的名字，我怎么还能成为外交官的妻子？我忘了第一夫人什么的。总统夫人斯洛博德金？拜托。新闻界会把我们活吞了。”
We'd try and point out my dad's lack of political aspirations. But our mom would just wave us away impatiently. And then finally, when she could not stand it a moment longer, she took action. She went to a judge and arranged to have my dad's name legally changed. My dad went along with it to keep the peace. And by the end of the day, my dad had gone from being Norman [? Slobodkin ?] to Norman Kine.
我们会试着指出我爸爸缺乏政治抱负。但我妈妈只是不耐烦地挥挥手。然后最后，当她一刻也忍受不了时，她采取了行动。她去找了一位法官，并安排把我爸爸的名字合法更改了。我爸爸为了维持和平顺从了。到那天结束时，我爸爸已经从诺曼·斯洛博德金变成了诺曼·凯恩（Kine）。
For a little while, this seemed to satisfy my mother. She would happily sign both her and his new name in big flowery loops. But then as time went by, and neither the marriage nor her life seemed to improve, she was forced to confront the real source of her unhappiness-- Norman.
有一段时间，这似乎满足了我妈妈。她会开心地用大大的花体圈圈签下她和他的新名字。但随着时间的推移，婚姻和她的生活似乎都没有改善，她被迫面对她不快乐的真正来源——诺曼。
"What kind of a name is that? Can you name one character from literature with that name? Or one great historical figure? I guess I'll have to accept the fact that I'll never be an astronaut's wife or own a fleet of ships. Commandeer Norman. It wouldn't happen in a million years."
“那是个什么名字？你能说出一个文学作品里有那个名字的角色吗？或者一位伟大的历史人物？我想我得接受事实了，我永远不会成为宇航员的妻子或拥有一支船队。指挥官诺曼。这在一百万年内都不会发生。”
And so, once again, a trip to the courthouse was made. When my dad came out, his first name was no longer Norman. It was Richard. He was now Richard Kine.
于是，又一次，去了法院。当我爸爸出来时，他的名字不再是诺曼。是理查德。他现在是理查德·凯恩。
By the time I was in college, my parents seemed to lead altogether separate lives. My mom started to go to a lot of self-help seminars. And my dad now seemed to be working at all hours of the day. My mom got an apartment that my dad didn't know about. And most shockingly, she began seeing another man. They went on a trip to Europe together in secret, my mom telling my dad that she'd gone to Palm Springs to visit her mom.
当我上大学时，我的父母似乎过着完全分开的生活。我妈妈开始参加很多自助研讨会。而我爸爸现在似乎每时每刻都在工作。我妈妈租了一套我爸爸不知道的公寓。而且最令人震惊的是，她开始见另一个男人。他们秘密地去欧洲旅行了一趟，我妈妈告诉爸爸她去了棕榈泉探望她妈妈。
They seemed to have perfected a schedule that entailed neither of them being in the same house for more than 10 minutes at a time. My mom went back to school and got her credentials to become a substitute teacher, which my dad also didn't know about. It was all so bizarre and extreme that I didn't even know where to start explaining it. I imagined calling my dad up in the middle of the night to break the news to him. "Dad, there's something I have to tell you. For the past few years, mom has been leading a double life. She has a secret apartment and a secret boyfriend. She is also a substitute teacher."
他们似乎已经完美地制定了一个时间表，包括他们两人在同一所房子里待的时间不超过10分钟。我妈妈回学校拿到了成为代课老师的资格证，我爸爸也不知道。这一切都太离奇和极端了，我甚至不知道从哪里开始解释。我想象在深夜打电话给爸爸告诉他这个消息。“爸爸，有一件事我必须告诉你。过去几年里，妈妈一直过着双重生活。她有一个秘密公寓和一个秘密男友。她也是一名代课老师。”
My dad, however, found out about it on his own. He hired a private detective and had my mom followed. And it was at that point that my father took what was, to him, the next logical step. Rather than putting an end to a marriage that he hadn't been happy in from the very start, he instead did the opposite. He put all of his energy into saving it.
然而，我爸爸是自己发现的。他雇了一名私家侦探，跟踪了我妈妈。就在那时，我父亲迈出了对他来说下一步合乎逻辑的一步。与其结束一段他从一开始就不幸福的婚姻，他反而做了相反的事。他把所有的精力都投入到挽救它上。
My dad started buying my mom presents all the time. They went to museums and for long drives up the coast. They sat up late at night and made plans for the future. This would go on for a while. But then I'd hear from my mom that things weren't working out, and that they were definitely going to do it-- get a divorce.
我爸爸开始一直给我妈妈买礼物。他们去博物馆，并沿着海岸长途开车。他们深夜坐在一起，为未来做计划。这会持续一段时间。但后来我会从妈妈那里听说事情没有好转，他们绝对要去做那件事——离婚。
A week later, I'd call my dad to see how he was holding up. And he'd tell me everything was going great. They were together again. This back and forth-- my hopes intermittently fulfilled then crushed-- went on for two whole years.
一周后，我会打电话给爸爸看看他怎么样了。他会告诉我一切都很好。他们又在一起了。这种来来回回——我的希望断断续续地实现然后破灭——持续了整整两年。
It got to the point that the only way I could tell if they were separated or not was by calling my dad's cell phone to see whether it said to leave a message for Richard Kine or for Norman [? Slobodkin. ?] When they were doing well, he was Richard. When they weren't, he went back to Norm.
到了这种地步，判断他们是否分居的唯一方法就是拨打我爸爸的手机，看看是留言让理查德·凯恩回电话，还是让诺曼·斯洛博德金回电话。当他们相处得好时，他是理查德。当他们没相处好时，他又回到了诺曼。
I asked my dad what he was thinking during this time. And he tells me that he'd decided to be the attentive loving husband that he'd never been before. So again, I ask him why.
我问我爸爸这段时间他在想什么。他告诉我他决定成为他以前从未做过的体贴、充满爱的丈夫。所以再次，我问他为什么。
It's quite a mystery why you fought so hard to keep this marriage together that you guys were never happy in. Like, never.
你为什么这么拼命想要维持这段你们从来都不幸福的婚姻，这真是一个谜。我是说，从来没有。
Because I felt that I was primarily responsible for her unhappiness.
因为我觉得她不快乐主要是我的责任。
That's not true, Dad.
那不是真的，爸爸。
Well, I'm just telling you. You're asking me a question. I'm giving you an answer.
嗯，我只是告诉你。你在问我一个问题。我在给你一个答案。
I know. I just don't want you to feel that way.
我知道。我只是不想让你有那种感觉。
Well, I mean healthy people don't feel unhappy without a reason.
嗯，我的意思是健康的人没有理由不会感到不快乐。
Yeah. But unhealthy people--
是的。但那些不健康的人——
Yeah.
是的。
And there it was, the reason my dad stayed with my mom for so long. He didn't see her as being different from a normal person. He wasn't even thinking about it that way. He just saw her as his wife. And right or wrong, he had to stick by her. For him, that's what it meant to be married.
就在那里，我爸爸和我妈妈待在一起那么久的原因。他不觉得她和普通人有什么不同。他甚至没有那样想过。他只是把她视为他的妻子。无论对错，他必须支持她。对他来说，那就是婚姻的意义。
Let's say, for an example, a person, male or female, gets into drugs or alcohol. So you say, what did I do, maybe, to cause this person to drink? What did I do to cause this person to become unhappy? To become moody? To become lethargic? To lose interest in life?
举个例子，一个人，无论男性还是女性，接触了毒品或酒精。所以你会说，我做了什么，也许，导致这个人喝酒？我做了什么导致这个人变得不快乐？变得喜怒无常？变得懒散？对生活失去兴趣？
And you're saying that's what happened with you?
你是说这就是发生在你身上的事？
I was convinced that I was a contributing force, yes. Give me half a second here. Hold on.
我确信我是推动力，是的。给我半秒钟。等一下。
At this point, my dad's other line rings. And he has to take the call. So he hands off the phone to his new girlfriend, Ruth.
此时，我爸爸的另一条电话响了。他不得不接电话。所以他把电话递给了他的新女友，露丝。
Hi, honey. How are you doing?
嗨，亲爱的。你怎么样？
I'm OK. Are you listening to all this?
我还可以。你在听这一切吗？
Yes, it's very interesting. Some things I knew, some things I didn't know.
是的，很有趣。有些事情我知道，有些事情我不知道。
Ruth and my dad have actually dated before, 34 years ago, before he had ever met my mom. They were engaged to be married, but Ruth broke it off because she hadn't felt ready. Then a few months ago, my dad looked her number up, and things took off from there.
露丝和我爸爸其实之前约会过，34年前，在他遇见我妈妈之前。他们曾经订婚准备结婚，但露丝取消了，因为她觉得还没准备好。几个月前，我爸爸查到了她的号码，事情就从那里开始了。
Were you surprised when my dad called you up?
我爸爸打电话给你时你惊讶吗？
Yeah. Oh, yeah. I just went, "How come you're calling?" And he goes, "Well, I'm divorced." I go, "Is it final?" And he goes, "Yes." I go, "Are you sure?" Because I didn't want to get into anything like that, you know? And he goes, "Yes, definitely. It's final." And so I go, "OK, well, then come around some time. And I'd like to hear what happened." And he said, "Oh, I'm only two miles away." So I go, "Well, then you can take me out to dinner."
是的。噢，是的。我只是说，“你怎么打电话来了？” 他说，“嗯，我离婚了。” 我说，“最后定了吗？” 他说，“是的。” 我说，“你确定吗？” 因为我不想卷入像那样的事情中，你知道吗？他说，“是的，绝对。最后定了。” 所以我说，“好吧，那么找个时间过来吧。我想听听发生了什么。” 他说，“噢，我就在两英里外。” 所以我说，“好吧，那么你可以带我去吃晚餐。”
Ruth is really, really nice. But the thing that gets me is how much she seems to like my dad. Now, because of her, he has this whole new life.
露丝真的，真的很不错。但让我不解的是她似乎多喜欢我爸爸。现在，因为她，他有了这个全新的生活。
My days are totally different. I wake up and there's breakfast on the table. I get a phone call from somebody during the day-- "How are you doing, love?" I'll call the person up, I'll say, you know, "I have to go to here, or there, or Timbuktu. You want to come along?" "Oh, sure." It's normal.
我的日子完全不同了。我醒来，桌上就有早餐。白天我接到一个电话——“你好吗，亲爱的？” 我会打给那个人，我会说，你知道，“我得去这里，或者那里，或者廷巴克图。你想一起去吗？” “噢，当然。” 这很正常。
Yeah. Normal is good, though, right?
是的。正常是件好事，对吧？
Yeah. Normal is fine.
是的。正常很好。
For the first time, my dad is discovering what it's like being with someone you like, someone you respect and who respects you, someone who is nice to you. My mom seems much happier these days too. When I talk to her, it's like a huge burden has been lifted from her shoulders.
第一次，我爸爸正在发现与一个你喜欢、你尊重且尊重你、对你很好的人在一起是什么感觉。我妈妈最近也看起来快乐多了。当我与她交谈时，就像一块巨大的负担从她的肩上卸下了。
In August, Ruth and my dad are going to Germany on vacation. It's my dad's first trip out of the country. He doesn't even have a passport. When I ask him which name he'll be putting on it, Norman or Richard, he just laughs and says, "Either one."
八月，露丝和我爸爸要去德国度假。这是我爸爸第一次出国旅行。他甚至没有护照。当我问他会在护照上填哪个名字，诺曼还是理查德，他只是笑了笑说，“随便哪一个都行。”
Starlee Kine.
斯塔莉·凯恩。
Well, our program is produced today by Sarah Koenig and myself with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Wendy Dorr, and Jane Golombisky. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Kelsey Dilts.
嗯，我们的节目今天由萨拉·凯尼格和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、戴安·库克、温迪·多尔和简·戈隆比斯基。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼和凯尔西·迪尔茨提供了制作协助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our programs for absolutely free. Recently, we've actually noticed on eBay the This American Life secret decoders that we were offering a few years back on our program are now selling for over $150 each. And I've got to say-- not to drive the price down or anything-- at our website, thisamericanlife.org, you can get the decoder plus four of our old shows that have secret coded messages in them for a third of the price. And the proceeds benefit public radio instead of some guy in Kalamazoo. You can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站 www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费地收听我们的节目。最近，我们实际上在 eBay 上注意到，我们几年前在节目中提供的《美国生活》秘密解码器现在的售价超过了150美元每个。我必须说——不是为了压低价格什么的——在我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，你可以以三分之一的价格得到那个解码器，外加我们四个包含秘密编码信息的旧节目。而且收益会惠及公共广播，而不是卡拉马祖的某个家伙。你可以在 audible.com/thisamericanlife 下载我们节目的音频。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金支持鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who reminded me just this morning--
WBEZ 对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他今天早上刚刚提醒我——
Well, you know you don't really have the kind of body on a man that I find really the most attractive.
嗯，你知道你的身材并没有让我觉得非常有吸引力。
I'm Ira Glass.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Will you shut up and let me finish?
你能不能闭嘴让我说完？
Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
Oh, I don't get to finish until you finish, is that it?
噢，我不让你说完你就说不完，是吗？
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。